let's just jump to the first big news
story and then we'll just roll with it
it's very simple from the hill supreme
court asked to declare the all-male
military draft unconstitutional the aclu
issued a new petition saying women
should be required
to register register for enlistment as
well
they say a new petition issued by the
aclu has made it to the supreme court
and aims to declare the historic
mail-only military draft
unconstitutional noting that the u.s
department of defense
lifted the ban on women serving in
combat in 2013. the petition specifies
that the obligation for men to register
upon turning 18 years old
has yet to be applied to women quote
thousands of women have since
served with distinction in combat
positions across all branches of the
military
the formal petition reads the
registration requirement has no
legitimate purpose
and cannot withstand the exacting
scrutiny of
sex-based laws that sex-based laws
require rooted in this argument is the
1981 case
rotsker v goldberg which argued that
because american men are required to
register under the u.s law and women are
not
the mail-only draft is discriminatory
and unconstitutional
the act gives u.s presidents the power
to require mandatory conscription of
eligible adult males into the us army
but excludes women ultimately the court
held that the act does not violate equal
protection clauses under the fifth
amendment
and that the government is allowed to
develop an army in times of national
emergency
now the petition asked the supreme court
to overrule rotzker v goldberg
since women are formally allowed to
register for military service and in
combat roles
and just as an aside i don't want to
derail from this story
we have the equality act being passed by
the house which would add
sex to the 1964 civil rights act so as
far as i'm concerned ladies
start lining up and registering for the
selective service because y'all are
going to be drafted
i have a question i i didn't realize
that there was still a draft
i i realized that when i was the age for
the draft i was
obese and and wouldn't have qualified i
also have flat feet but
did you guys all register for the draft
yes you did
yeah i i don't remember well you're
you're 141 do you mean you have to if
you go to college
sir like you have to apply for
registered to vote yeah yeah like when
you were doing when you would i
go to the dmv they give you forms it
would be like i sold i signed up for the
selective service and then
i had no idea yeah yeah now
they they say that the all uh volunteer
force is more effective
and i think that's true like the data
shows
you get a bunch of people who don't want
to be there who are scared and forced
into it you get a really
ineffective fighting force i think
that's what they learned from vietnam
so my bigger question with all of this
is i know there's a lot of guys who are
probably laughing and cheering
like yeah yeah finally because we've
seen this before there was another
attempt at
at making this happen and feminists were
outraged
they were like this is not what i wanted
when when i said i wanted equality
i do not want to have to go to war and
fight in combat or anything like that
and it's like well that's what equality
means
but i guess there's a libertarian
question in all this should there be a
draft
i mean i'm sure look like i said there's
people like guys who are like ah now you
have to
sign up for the draft i'm kind of like
nah i don't know if anybody should have
to do that right
well if you look at what wars were
fighting they're not really wars
promoting freedom they're not really
wars fighting any kind of threat and i
think henry kissinger
uh you know he has this famous quote he
said quote military men are just
dumb stupid animals to be used as pawns
in american foreign said that
i confronted him on it face to face
one-on-one he didn't like that question
uh but but now we need an official
correction for mr kissinger he needs to
state
uh specifically that military men and
women and women
are now just dumb stupid animals to be
used as funds for foreign policy so we
need an official correction i hope the
mainstream media pressures mr henry
kissinger to to offer this question i'm
being fascist obviously here
but but i mean obviously i'm against the
draft i mean i think it's a ridiculous
idea you look at the wars that been
started
all of them are based on false pretenses
all of them are based on
benefiting the military-industrial
complex that is now getting their lunch
with the biden presidency especially
with the latest attacks that happened
tonight
but also even before that when you look
at raytheon for an example which by the
way
a board member is now our defense
secretary that
uh of raytheon that's great yeah uh yeah
well it's it's it's very what did they
call it in the media when they described
him
um he was a person of color and that was
great
uh his diversity yeah it was it was they
talked about diversity but not his
raytheon pass and now you look at what
the biden administration is doing at
raytheon raytheon just got an 85 million
dollar weapons deal with
chile 197 million dollar weapons deal in
egypt
245 million dollar weapons deal with the
united states and another 1.2 billion
dollar weapons deal
with u.s missile defense systems that's
what raytheon just got under a biden
presidency but wait wait you said
missile defense systems uh upgrading and
working on the military but will there
be will there be women
forced through conscription to be
manning those that's the big question
right now there there was a i remember
just a few years ago there was a crisis
with trying to enlist
uh people in the military but now with
how robotic everything is becoming
especially with the onset
of things like drone warfare the united
states military doesn't need as many
people and with
the recent economic downturn more people
are volunteering so right now the united
states does not need to use
uh the draft but if there was a bigger
conflict let's just say with russia
which of course the united states is
positioning itself with especially with
tonight's actions bombing
a syrian uh you know a syrian facility
that's used by the iranian-backed rebels
uh you have to wonder that this is this
is something that might
play a big role in the future i wonder
if one of the reasons we're seeing this
it's not the first time it's happened in
the past few years there have been
attempts to get women
into combat roles and to sign up for
it's not it's not the draft specifically
it's the selective service
i think it's called as it was called and
then it's essentially the draft database
that in the event they have to reinstate
the draft
they got everybody's info but we've been
we've been talking about
china for quite a bit i mean the threat
from the south china sea
and uh the threat to taiwan i'm not
entirely convinced biden's going to go
against
china in that capacity but maybe the u.s
has currently
got i think some aircraft carriers in
the south china sea could be remnants
from the trump administration
but we seem to be pretty close to war i
think uh was it vladimir putin
who said that we're in a period it's
kind of like pre-world war ii
you know then we're looking we see
things like that we see the money supply
i don't know ethan have you seen this
stuff with the money supply skyrocketing
like just like printing money like crazy
so i wonder if they're basically saying
we need to start preparing
and putting together this database in
the event that we gotta
go fight some people you know i'm really
anti-war
and really dislike the draft i would
have been if
vietnam one of those guys that fled to
canada probably because i didn't want to
go what's wrong with mexico
stuffed in a tube go crawl through
tunnels with a
pistol looking for dudes with aks
waiting for me like
no but you sure you want to also
refrigerator for repairman or something
yeah i don't want to get inside of a
refrigerator for a repair man is that
what you just said
i said do what what i said something
like
wouldn't you have been a refrigerator
repair yeah it would have been something
like that in the army and i get it
um but then they would send those guys
into the jungle you'd be like i'm an
engineer yeah you're an engineer on the
front line it was terrible terrible but
but i see a value to the draft in that
if we were invaded you got to get people
you got to get them armed and get them
in and you're not waiting
hoping that they'll come to the end of
the country i'm like i'm like
i'm like like if we get invaded but we
don't get invaded
never have been invaded yeah
geopolitically the united states is at a
very very big advantage compared to a
lot of other countries where it's
located
so we're in a very safe safe position as
well as many gun owners that of course
also added
another big national defense and there
was a meme showing all the crazy people
that lived all over the united states
and it was a meme saying this is why the
united states never gets invaded
south los angeles it was koreans
and then under that it was vatos and
then it was gang members in chicago
it was florida man in florida hicks in
texas i forgot exactly all the other
uh representation of america but the
chicago police can't even take over
chicago
america will never be invaded fifth
generational warfare is the only way
to really take over the united states
and i believe that's personally
happening right now yeah it is yeah
there was a really funny tweet i saw
earlier where it was uh uh from
i think the website was the gray zone
which is like anti-war leftist
and they tweeted information war is real
and twitter added a label this
information may have been obtained
through hacking
and then it's like twitter literally
proved the point that we try and call
out these big military firms and the
manipulation and the propaganda
twitter itself is like this is
propaganda ignore this there's nothing
to see here
so yeah you know what like i brought up
you know china and potential for war
i think we might i think you'll just see
skirmishing you know skirmishes
some little hot you know back and forth
maybe like hong kong
if if china goes for taiwan it's not
going to be
well it might be i'm not entirely sure
but i think you're right
in that you know luke we've been talking
about fifth generational warfare are you
familiar with what no i don't know what
fifth generational warfare means
basically we're past the point where
violence is effective
in allowing someone to gain control of a
population
and what we're seeing from that is like
with the culture war in the us
victimhood is power so if you victimize
someone you lose legitimacy
so what we're seeing now manipulation
propaganda
convince populations to join you through
information
manipulation big tech companies etc it's
going to be way more effective than
you know physically punching somebody
right and also push self-destructive
tendencies and also push
things that ultimately destroy a nation
through destroying their youth
and if you look at our youth i mean i
did a video about this today
uh record high suicides especially in
places where there's the most
strictest lockdowns and there's even
court cases of of major people arguing
we need to
bring back the schools because kids are
going to keep killing themselves in
record numbers like they already are
which is absolutely the lockdown stuff's
getting real bad i mean how would you
rank
americans i mean i mean i think you're
our age
throughout the years i i think it's safe
to say that things haven't been going
that well for the american people
i think i'm a little older than you guys
how old are you 44
well you're a little bit older than ian
41 but you're 10 years older than me
yeah there you go
thank god i thought you were gonna say
no we're the same age
you know at the end of the day i think
that all of the things that we think of
as having power in america
are all just ideas and so
if these structures i think that the way
to
uh dissolve them isn't through warm
violence
for real it is just to convince people
that's exactly what this generational
war is
yeah but i i think like like if you look
at how the ussr
kind of dissolved and it got really
rough immediately following the
dissolution of the ussr
and there was a lot of scary stuff
happening over there yeah
but people just went like i don't want
to do this anymore
yeah it was a loss loss of confidence
right i'm worried about that for here in
the us
you know like if people stop believing
in the legitimacy of government
or of institutions it's not about
whether or not they oppose them
opposition is not the op is so so
opposition is not the opposite of
confidence
indifference would be so if you've got
people who are looking to the us
government and they're saying
i believe in this government in that
it's strong and capable
and you must abide by its laws and
honest that's a big thing too
and well if people view it as not honest
and they come to oppose it
the opposition is still rooted in the
idea that the government holds power and
is legitimate
but let's say there's a system that
people find they're indifferent to
so they outright ignore that's when
government actually collapses
yeah i agree well the thing is there's a
there's a lot of people losing
confidence in the system because of all
the
dishonesty there's a great article i
forgot who wrote it i forgot
where i read it but it said the reason
we have things like
you know uh theories about you know
government i can't can we even say that
word
the oh the c-word yeah can we even say
the c-word i don't know
what's the c-word well we
yeah youtube down ranks like severely
anybody you thought yeah
i was trying to think of another word
for it i threw it to you because you're
great at that
but when you when you look at a lot of
the conspiracy theories that you know
they're they're kind of rooted
in a lot of the bigger government lies
and there wouldn't be
as many of them if the government was
just honest with us and let's be honest
they're not honest with us in so many
instances in so many
different ways whether it's war whether
it's health whether it's diet whether
it's the food
chain whether it's big industries like
the sugar industry
we have a lot of problems with mainline
institutions that profit off of our
suffering
and talking along the lines of fifth
generational warfare i think it's very
fair to say that a lot of people have
been convinced to make very bad
decisions for themselves and i think
that's an understatement when you look
at our modern day society and where it's
headed right now
well let's play let's play devil's
advocate and say
you know when talking about the draft
and uh
specifically refresh me on what your
point was because i want to make sure i
get it correct
the larger point is people are making
really bad decisions for themselves and
they're hurting themselves for the
benefit of the very few that have no
allegiance to
the united states so just like playing
devil's advocate
if we did end up collapsing and people
did lose confidence you know ethan you
mentioned things got really bad
post-soviet union
you know the oligarchs came isn't there
isn't there a benefit to having
even if it's bad and again playing
devil's advocate here because i'm not a
big fan of big government
but what are the benefits to having a
system in place that may be oppressive
but still functions their safety and
security but by the way it
it it got bad there it doesn't have to
get bad here you know
i think i think there's a weird thing
that happens in america with the medium
with government and stuff like that you
know
the um the blue and black and and white
and gold dress
and then laurel yani how people can
actively experience objective reality
differently
now i didn't when my kids first showed
me this and said what color do you see
and i said well that's clearly i don't
remember what it i think i said it's a
a black a white and gold whatever it was
and my kid said no it's these colors i
thought
you're messing with me this is clearly i
mean objectively not the colors you're
saying it is
and they insisted and then it turns out
lots of people saw it differently
there's no room in
political discourse or or or just
culture
for us to go that person is experiencing
this
differently than i am right i really try
to think about like people
arguing in line at a baskin robbins over
ice cream flavors
and at the end of the day i'm going like
what difference does it make why are we
allowing
this to ruin our lives and why are we
obsessing on it everybody likes a
different flavor right i did a tweet
where i said we really need to
re-engage scienceology and go deep into
it rip it apart and come back and i was
talking about the science of science
like
and so many people thought i said
scientology they were responding as if
i'd said scientology
and they were angry and it's just like
misperception
and that's that's not even the blue gold
thing where you're actually literally
seeing
they actually saw something different i
do i do want to bring up though when you
mention the blue and gold thing
one of the biggest drivers of that was
people had different phones with
different color
schemes and with the laurel and yanny
thing people had different speakers
so what was really happening but i could
sit with my friends oh no for sure and
listen to it and somebody's going no i
hear yanny
there's a really amazing thing someone
did where they took both
the blue and gold and the white of the
white and gold and the blue and the
black
and they cut a piece out and they moved
it left and right to show you it was the
same
wow or or yeah like like uh but it was
based on
shadowing like shading made it was like
what that really looks like that's crazy
how that works
and then there's another thing that's
really funny there's a meme where it was
i think seven different phrases but it
was one sound bite
and so whichever one phrase you read you
would hear
that's that's really freaky wow i can't
remember what it was i think it was
uh like iphone for us and then it was
like a whole bunch of different phrases
and you hear it differently if you if
you look at the word and you read it and
listen
you'll hear that right there was another
crazy experiment i saw where they had
people say
and then they would play like someone
saying
ba but show the f sound and people would
hear the f sound
because they're seeing like people don't
realize how much their world view is is
is like not perfect right
yeah yeah i mean i i think you make a
good point that a lot of what's going on
politically is that like
actually have you ever seen this meme
where there's a six on the ground or
it's a nine
but there's two people on both sides
looking at it saying six or nine yeah
that's like a good example of what we're
experiencing right now and it's causing
people to like want to punch each other
in the face yeah i also get
a little hung up with the idea of should
um
when we think about all of this stuff
and i hear people saying this is how it
should be
i kind of go like well that's how you
want it to be
but really what it should mean you know
even when we're talking about science
science doesn't have values people add
values to science
so right anytime somebody is saying
something should be a way i'm i'm kind
of like okay
maybe you and a bunch of people don't
want it to be that way or you and a
bunch of people do want it to be that
way and i think it's really interesting
to listen to
people who say here's this problem that
i perceive
and here's a solution that i'd like to
try and enact
but like that's a rational conversation
but you know that meme where it's like
the guy goes i'm angry
and he says here's a solution i don't
he's like i'm mad he's a solution i
don't want a solution i want to be mad
and he's burning it yeah
that's fair too you sound like a very uh
uh what what
what are the uh the leftists insult they
say radical centrist yeah
that you're like hey maybe maybe
everybody has like a different
understanding of things
no you're either in our tribe or you're
bad right well yeah i mean look at the
end of the day
i i also don't think there is i don't
think everybody should be
forced to uh adhere to the same
structures
so if if people want to be
communist i'm all for it i just don't
think
i should have to be forced to be a
communist that's why i like the sweater
i thought it was the anarchist symbol
but it's your podcast right it's just a
podcast that's why i like that i'm like
yeah yeah
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you